so  in my vast spare time i do dabble in  video game  making because wolfram language has  unity link you can create assets  like geometry assets from within the  wolfram language and then import them  very easily i went and actually worked  on  castlevania so i have a surface book  here which is a microsoft device and  i've got an xbox controller  and i just wanted to show how easy it is  for the wolfram language to connect to  external devices  i did include a double jump in here even  though it's not required for this kind  of game  and so i included died already i did  it's running a little fast  so even though i did scale back a lot of  what my original grand design was  it was still a really good learning  project and actually give it  credit for me getting a job in the front  end team nice  so if you want to get into programming i  think games are a great way to do it  even if that doesn't become your  profession  you